zone Europe
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 une émission
spéciale enregistrée à Europa expérience
un lieu interactif et gratuit
entièrement consacré à l'Europe et au
fonctionnement des institutions
reportage de Mathis Godefroy on
apprendrons davantage sur l'Union
européenne et son fonctionnement de
façon ludique et amusante à la fois
c'est possible en plein Paris 1500
mètres carrés d'expérience interactive
pour en savoir plus sur l'Europe en
général Europa expérience on vous emmène
alors bonjour Leila vous allez nous
faire la visite aujourd'hui de d'Europe
expérience et je crois que la visite du
coup elle va commencer par le bas le
sous-sol c'est bien ça qu'est-ce qu'on
va y voir
c'est un film immersif sur l'Europe
[Musique]
augmenter et c'est une carte de l'Europe
mais sans frontières et ça c'est ça
qu'on veut montrer aussi que l'Europe
est unie sans frontières ok donc là on
peut prendre une tablette et on apprend
un peu plus du coup sur l'Europe en
général oui c'est ça
vous voyez il y a déjà Barcelone qui
apparaît je peux me balader je peux
aller vers la France Paris par exemple
et cliquez sur Paris et voir ce qui se
passe à Paris et côté européen il y a
une liaison ferroviaire et européen qui
a été construit et donc on peut cliquer
et voir une petite vidéo et donc là-bas
il y a une deuxième table sur le
Parlement la Commission et les toutes
les institutions un petit peu
européennes
ici on voit justement les trois
institutions il y a le Conseil la
Commission et le Parlement européen et
donc le fameux triangle institutionnel
est représenté du coup par les lignes
qu'on voit ici et justement ça c'est
leur interaction et c'est ça qu'on
essaye de montrer sur cette table c'est
que les trois institutions ils
travaillent ensemble
Paris vous avez aussi la possibilité de
faire un jeu de rôle un immersion de
deux heures en incarnant les euros
députés
à présent je vous propose de voir ou de
revoir les temps forts de nos interviews
avec les députés européens
zone Europe le best of
bonjour Pierre larouto bonjour vous êtes
heureux député membre du groupe de
l'Alliance progressiste des socialistes
et démocrates au Parlement européen et
vous êtes membre de la commission des
budgets on va parler avec vous
aujourd'hui d'un projet qui vous révolte
le projet de Total ecope c'est comme ça
qu'on les nomme une des plus grandes
entreprises françaises totales qui est
spécialisée dans le domaine de l'énergie
totale à selon ses chiffres 279 en
poiriers en Ouganda c'est là où donc se
situe ce nouveau projet l'entreprise est
la numéro 1 en matière de distribution
dans ce pays elle possède la batte 200
stations services le groupe a annoncé
donc le premier février 2022 investir 10
milliards d'euros dans un projet
d'oléoduc avec un partenaire chinois
knock donc un oléoduc je le précise
c'est une canalisation pour transporter
le pétrole ce projet donc et validé par
les aut ougandaise et tanzanienne aussi
alors total va exploiter et exporter ce
pétrole ougandais donc jusque en
Tanzanie pour ensuite le redistribuer
cette oléodie que l'impressionne par sa
taille 1443 km et permettra donc
d'extraire 230 000 barils brutes de
pétrole par jour alors voilà pour les
chiffres vous vous dénoncez cette
l'impact climatique
mais total pas son temps à dire ils
appellent maintenant total énergie ils
passent leur temps à dire qu'ils ont
changé quand vous voyez les publicités à
Bruxelles à Strasbourg ou à Paris on
voit que des énergies renouvelables mais
en fait 75% des investissements
aujourd'hui de total c'est dans les
énergies fossiles alors que il y a un an
vous en souvenez c'était à l'une des
échos le l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie disait que si on veut éviter
un avenir apocalyptique il faut stopper
immédiatement tous les nouveaux forages
de gaz et de pétrole cet été en France
on a eu trois canicules on a eu plus de
10000 morts on a eu des feux de forêt en
Bretagne quand j'étais petit personne
pensait qu'on aurait des feux de forêts
en Bretagne il y a eu des inondations
Catastro au Pakistan ou en Inde voilà
donc tout le monde se demande comment
stopper le dérèglement climatique tout
le monde sait y compris un Ouganda et en
tant d'années qu'on peut faire des
énergies renouvelables mais malgré tout
malgré tout total continu à faire des
investissements fossiles et ce sont les
pires je sais pas si on peut faire un
zoom là-dessus ça c'est l'ensemble des 8
plus grandes médias pétrole et gaz au
niveau mondial elle continue tout un peu
les investissements fossiles mais la
numéro 1 pour le pétrole et pour le gaz
dans les quatre années qui viennent
c'est total donc c'est vraiment
scandaleux et ce projet en Ouganda il y
a déjà 20 banques qui ont dit non ce
projet est tellement catastrophique pour
le climat pour la biodiversité ils vont
faire des forages dans le plus beau parc
naturel de Ganda vous avez des girafes
des lions des éléphants et c'est là
qu'ils veulent commencer à la fin de
l'année des forages il y a 100 000
personnes qui sont concernées des
paysans souvent total leur demande de ne
plus exploiter leur terre normalement
mais ça fait quatre ans que vous
attendent de l'argent donc j'ai vu on a
passé 9 jours en Ouganda nous cet été on
a vu des enfants qui vont plus à l'école
depuis 4 ans parce que les parents n'ont
plus de quoi vivre et n'ont plus de quoi
payer l'école donc c'est juste un
scandale à tout point de vue on n'est
pas les seul ça se révolter il y a déjà
20 banques qui ont dit non la Dolce Bank
a dit non BNP a dit non Barclays a dit
non et puis vous l'avez dit il y a à moi
le Parlement européen quand on est
revenu de Ganda on a fait voter par
l'ensemble de ce Parlement une
résolution pour dire stop icoop stop ce
projet stop définitivement les forages
dans le parc naturel et stop pendant un
an tout le projet pour réfléchir à des
renouvelables et donc maintenant le but
est de mettre la pression sur total mais
aussi sur le Crédit Agricole et sur
Amundi qui sont ses principaux
actionnaires justement de multiples
recours judiciaires sont en cours de la
part de engie française et ougandaise
notamment les Amis de la Terre ou en
sont les recours aujourd'hui et est-ce
qu'ils peuvent vraiment faire donc
changer cette décision du gouvernement
ouganden qui est tout de même souverain
sur sur ces terres bien sûr le
gouvernement Gandé est souverain et je
suis en contact des ambassadeurs avec
des parlementaires on va tout faire pour
leur montrer c'est un point fondamental
parce qu'il s'agit pas de stopper le
pipeline et que ce soit des Chinois ou
des Américains qui le reprennent donc
aussi y compris les arguments de
d'ailleurs que quoi qu'il arrive le
projet se fera et si c'est pas nous ce
sera d'abord des entreprises chinoises
ou américains
est arrivé à la Maison Blanche je dois
dire signe un décret pour dire les
États-Unis reviennent dans l'accord de
Paris et 5 minutes après Joe Biden signe
un décret pour dire on stoppe le
pipeline question XL vous êtes voilà
donc il y a une cohérence en principe et
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours
Emmanuel Macron était sur France 2 on
lui a demandé est-ce que vous soutenez
ce pipeline il a dit que la France ne le
soutenait oui mais en fait c'est ambigu
il a pas dit non plus qu'il voulait
l'arrêter donc nous le Parlement la
position du Parlement européen est très
claire on veut stopper ce pipeline et
comme un des responsables du budget j'ai
été rapporté en général il buvien en
2021 je vais tout faire pour qu'il y ait
de l'argent mis sur la table parce que
l'Ouganda au début ne voulait pas ce
projet c'est total c'est le patron de
Total pour y aller qui a convaincu
monsieur moussavini le Président ougandé
et pourquoi est-ce que le gouvernement
Gand est intéressé en l'air un
parc naturel c'est pas leur objectif
faire du pétrole pour le reste du monde
qui va polluer la planète c'est pas leur
objectif mais le Ganda a besoin d'argent
et on peut très bien le comprendre le
grand a besoin d'argent pour un système
l'éducation nationale qui soit gratuit
aujourd'hui l'éducation est payante en
Ouganda et le gouvernement voudrait un
système gratuit bravo et un système
d'électricité ils auront bientôt trop
d'hydroélectricité et des grands
barrages ils ont bien de faire un réseau
électrique donc je pense qu'on peut très
vite arriver à un accord entre l'Union
européenne et l'Ouganda en disant si
vous renoncez à ce pétrole on vous met
de l'argent sur la table pendant 25 ans
et c'est pas moi qui ai eu l'idée en
termes de développement notamment en
termes d'aide au développement mais avec
deux lettres qui est 100% des dons et
pas des des prêts et en fait l'idée
n'est pas de moi c'est en 2007 c'était
le patron de l'Équateur le président de
l'équateur Raphaël Correa qui avait une
idée assez géniale Raphaël Correa
président de l’équateur et fait un très
beau discours en disant j'ai du pétrole
dans mon sous-sol je peux y renoncer si
on me donne de l'argent en compensation
et au bout de trois ans il avait négocié
avec les Nations Unies vous voyez là le
symbole de l'équateur et des Nations
Unies un accord passionnant très très
concret sur comment on vérifie qu'on a
stoppé le pétrole combien on a d'argent
comment on contrôle que l'argent ne va
pas dans la poche de quelques-uns mais
va pour le bien commun qu'est-ce qu'on
fait sur la biodiversité sur l'éducation
sur les services publics donc l'accord
signé par l'équateur et les Nations
Unies peut nous servir de modèle à
l'époque il y avait pas eu d'argent mais
encore hier j'étais en échange avec une
quelqu'un qui était ministre à l'époque
et qui dit peut-être qu'on avait 15 ans
d'avance mais que maintenant 2022 les
gens ont compris l'urgence donc voilà
encore je suis un peu soufflé pas je
sors d'une autre réunion mais encore
hier matin à 9h du matin je plaidais
pour que on trouve les moyens
budgétaires très vite de dire à
l'Ouganda on n'est pas là pour vous
donner des leçons c'est vous qui décidez
mais en Ouganda aussi il y a du
dérèglement climatique le premier jour
qu'on est arrivé à Kampala elle a une
des journaux c'était 900 morts à cause
de la sécheresse voilà très concrètement
le jour on est arrivé à Kampala avec mes
collègues députés 900 morts dans le nord
de l'Ouganda à cause de la sécheresse et
le dernier jour 30 morts à cause des
inondations donc en Ouganda aussi ils
veulent lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique la question intervalle que
l'Europe fait du blabla est-ce que
l'Europe donne des leçons de morale ou
est-ce que l'Europe est capable de
sortir le chéquier pour une nouvelle
coopération vous l'avez dit donc le
Parlement européen a adopté cette
résolution dénonçant ce projet
d'extraction pét en Ouganda c'était le
15 septembre dernier mais total répond
donc l'entreprise n'a pas été sollicitée
avant l'adoption de cette de cette
résolution et qu'elle n'a pas pu se
défendre au Parlement européen le PDG de
Total a donc décidé de ne pas se rendre
à une autre audition qui était prévue le
11 octobre cette fois par la Commission
des droits humains du Parlement européen
cela fait pourtant un bon moment que
vous essayez de de problèmes de rapport
à la vérité je vais pas dire qu'il ment
mais ça il ressemble beaucoup d'abord à
titre personnel et avec un des plus
grands climatologues français Jean Josel
à trois reprises on a demandé à Monsieur
pouyanet une rencontre depuis le mois de
mai il y a une fois on arrive au pied de
la tour total on arrivait aussi à les au
total à Paris enfin la défense et là le
conseiller politique de puyanais me dit
que le rendez-vous est annulé parce que
ce que j'ai dit sur les réseaux sociaux
a beaucoup énervé monsieur pouillané
voilà mais donc en tout cas à trois
reprises on a demandé rendez-vous et on
n'était même physiquement au siège total
et après ça avec nos collègues députés
on a passé 9 jours en Ouganda et à trois
reprises on a rencontré les dirigeants
de Total Ouganda le cinquième
n'a pas de très bons arguments mais il
sera devant la justice vous l'avez dit
il a pu refuser pour le moment de venir
devant le Parlement mais la justice
française c'est la première entreprise
qui va être devant la justice à cause de
la loi sur le devoir de vigilance la loi
sur le devoir de vigilance il ne doit
très importante qui a été votée il y a
quelques années qui dit en gros que ce
qui n'est pas possible de faire en
France ou en Europe une entreprise n'a
pas le droit de le faire dans les pays
du Sud en pensant que ça va pas se voir
et donc c'est la première fois qu'une
entreprise est devant la justice total a
tout fait depuis deux ans pour que le
procès soit repoussé repoussé mais le 7
décembre ça y est le juge a dit
maintenant on ne décale plus il y a un
arrêt de la Cour de cassation et puis le
juge encore il y a quelques jours a dit
le 7 décembre les avocats de total
seront devant répondre à nos questions
donc on va pas les lâcher et de même le
texte du Parlement européen mais devant
la responsabilité les actionnaires de
Total les steak holders c'est le Crédit
Agricole c'est à Mundi le Crédit
Agricole on le dit que c'est une banque
verte c'est la banque des agriculteurs
mais en fait ce sont les premiers
financeurs et les premiers actionnaires
de Total et c'est quand même assez
choquant cet été dans tous les
départements de France les paysans
n'avaient pas assez d'eau pour leur
culture dans la plupart des départements
les paysans ont dû tuer une partie de
leur bête ou vendre une partie du
troupeau parce qu'il n'avait plus assez
d'herbe à cause de la sécheresse donc
les agriculteurs sont directement
impactés par le dérèglement climatique
et le Crédit Agricole est le premier
financeur et le premier actionnaire de
Total donc j'ai demandé à rendez-vous
pour voir bientôt les patrons du Crédit
Agricole mais eux aussi devraient
prendre plus sérieusement leur
responsabilité et à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission on a appris
aussi un nouveau projet aura étant en
pour parler celui du total en Afrique du
Sud en Afrique du Sud total vraiment ce
sont les pires j'en ai honte plusieurs
fois je me suis exclus dans que comme
français j'en ai honte mais vraiment ce
sont les pires dans toutes les grandes
entreprises de pétrole ce sont les pires
pour les investissements et donc en
Afrique du Sud ils veulent faire à 150
km des côtes dans un endroit où il y a
une biodiversité marine magnifique ils
veulent forer pour trouver du gaz on
vous révisera pour en reparler merci
beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes heureux
débuté membre du groupe des
progressistes des socialistes et des
démocrates des européen nouvelle donne
au Parlement européen et porte-parole de
nouvelles données merci
zone Europe le best of
bonjour Christophe gruddler bonjour vous
êtes heureux député membre du groupe
Rignoux Europe au Parlement européen et
vous êtes également membre de la
commission de l'industrie de la
recherche et de l'énergie avec plusieurs
collègues européens vous vous êtes
rendus en octobre en Suisse pour évoquer
les relations entre le pays et l'Union
européenne une mission plutôt logique
pour vous vous venez de belles forts
juste à côté de la frontière Franco
Suisse mais revenons un peu en arrière
d'abord la Suisse est entourée de pays
qui font partie de l'Union européenne
mais pourtant elle elle n'en fait pas
partie d'où ça vient alors il y a
historiquement le fait que la Suisse
c'est quand même une agglomération de
cantons qui ont dit non à l'Empire à
l'empire des Habsbourg au Moyen-Âge à la
fin du Moyen-Âge et donc il y a cette
tradition aussi d'exister par soi-même
au niveau suisse sauf que aujourd'hui la
est complètement interconnecté avec les
pays voisins dépend en partie du marché
intérieur européen auquel elle a eu
jusqu'à maintenant un accès qu'on va
qualifier de privilégier de l'attente de
relation institutionnelles plus fort et
donc voilà donc il y a cette singularité
Suisse que il faut absolument respecter
tout en ayant la volonté que la Suisse
puisse être intégrée dans un mouvement
plus global parce qu'on a les mêmes
valeurs humaines la même notion de la
justice de la liberté de la presse par
exemple il y a des valeurs humaines en
général mais depuis de longues années
les relations entre l'Union européenne
et la Suisse ont vu la signature de
plusieurs accords bilatéraux
en fonction de différents secteurs à
commencer par celui du libre-échange en
1972 puis plein d'autres parmi lesquels
l'accord sur la libre circulation
l'accord sur l'échange automatique de
renseignements en matière fiscale mais
aussi donc
l'accord sur l'association complète de
la Suisse à horizon 2020 un programme
donc pour la recherche et l'Union
d'innovation alors selon vous qu'est-ce
qui bien fonctionné pour l'instant dans
ces accords bilatéraux et à l'inverse
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas encore
totalement est-ce qu'on pourrait être
amené à développer davantage alors il
faut faire un rapid historique pour bien
comprendre les choses parce que en fait
la Suisse envisagée un moment soit
d'adhérer l'Union européenne soit
d'adhérer à l'Espace économique européen
et dans ce cadre-là il y a eu en cadeau
de bienvenue quelque part des accords
bilatéraux qui ont été signés sur des
secteurs spécifiques il y a eu
pratiquement 110 accords bilatéraux qui
ont été signés avec la Suisse et en 1992
il y a eu un une votation en Suisse qui
a dit non à l'Espace économique européen
donc ça a un peu calmé un peu les choses
voilà et donc par contre les les accords
bilatéraux qui étaient faits pour 10 12
ou 15 ans donc il y avait une durée
limitée et bien
sont restés figés sur ces 10 ans et donc
pendant ce temps l'Union européenne et
la Suisse ont négocier ce qu'on appelle
un accord cadre dont la négociation a
commencé en 2014 et malheureusement on
met 2021 la partie Suisse arrêtée une
nuit littéralement les négociations pour
dire non on veut pas de cet accord cadre
donc au bout de allez on va dire 10 à 15
ans de négociation enfin de négociation
exploratoire d'abord et puis après de
négociation pure et bien on a on a perdu
15 ans et on est revenu avec une page
blanche donc aujourd'hui ce qui manque
clairement c'est un accord
institutionnel à minima avec la Suisse
pour lui permettre de bénéficier de
l'ensemble des secteurs thématiques qui
l'intéressent et qui l'intéresse aussi
l'Union européenne parce que ce type
d'accord c'est un accord où tout le
monde s'y retrouve c'est l'intérêt de la
Suisse c'est également l'intérêt de
l'Union européenne donc il faut juste
mettre le curseur au bon endroit pour
que il y ait quelque chose d'équilibré
entre entre nos deux entités alors du
coup depuis cette année le Conseil
fédéral de Suisse a souhaité relancer
donc ces discussions avec l'Union
européenne alors c'est dans ce contexte
que vous avez visité la Suisse ce que
vous êtes rendu dans le pays quels
étaient les objectifs de ce de ce voyage
et qu'est-ce que vous y avez fait alors
déjà il faut voir que les parlementaires
européens départements sont en relation
toute l'année
ils sont observateurs au niveau de
l'espace économique européen et donc on
a une fois par an une réunion qui se
déroule sans en Suisse soit dans l'Union
européenne pour justement essayer un
petit peu un petit peu d'avancer alors
j'allais dire que en tant que membre de
la délégation Union européenne Suisse on
est un peu plus diplomate que
parlementaire quelque part puisque on
fait beaucoup de relationsnel pour
expliquer aussi l'intérêt de déboucher
rapidement parce que c'est la tente des
citoyens tout simplement les citoyens
européens et les citoyens suisses
veulent un accord avec l'Union
européenne d'un côté et veut l'accord
avec la Suisse de l'autre donc en fait
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de rencontrer il
y a dix jours la présidente du Conseil
national suisse le président du Conseil
des États et puis à côté de Zurich la
semaine dernière un rappeursfield j'ai
eu l'occasion d'échanger avec la
secrétaire d'État en charge des affaires
étrangères de la Suisse madame l'oeil
avec laquelle voilà on essaye de faire
avancer les choses évidemment à notre
niveau on n'est pas non plus plaisir de
la Commission européenne du Conseil
européen mais au plus concret on a les
moyens de convaincre les moyens de dire
qu'il faut aller de l'avant ou citer le
programme Horizon Europe c'est c'est
majeur la Suisse a une recherche donc
c'est les fonds de recherche pour
préciser à une recherche absolument
exceptionnelle on a besoin de la Suisse
pour porter nos thématiques sur le
Cantique sur les semi-conducteurs sur
sur l'espace aussi que il y a vraiment
beaucoup de domaines sur lesquels il
faut vraiment renforcer une relation
avec la Suisse et puis essayer de
trouver les éclaircissements les les
plus les les plus complets pour ce qui
l'inquiète aujourd'hui parce que il y a
une partie de la population suisse qui a
peur de l'Europe qui a peur notamment du
droit dynamique européen puisque en fait
le nouvel accord qui est proposé par
l'Union européenne c'est la reprise du
droit européen systématique dans le
droit suisse et donc certains ont peur
de ça donc il faut expliquer que c'est
ça va pas remettre en cause de droit
suisse ça va être un droit en plus pour
les citoyens suisses dans le de cet
accord avec l'Europe vous êtes je l'ai
dit membre de la commission de
l'industrie de la recherche et de
l'énergie alors l'énergie justement en
France on manque actuellement
d'électricité la Suisse elle a de par
ses montagnes elle a construit de
nombreux barrages hydroélectriques il y
a des accords à développer au niveau
européen au niveau de l'énergie alors
très clairement pour moi une fois qu'on
aura ce chapeau institutionnel il faut
absolument qu'il y ait un accord sur
l'énergie que la Suisse alors dans les
deux sens parce que aujourd'hui
l'énergie hydraulique Suisse c'est
surtout de l'hydraulique de chutes d'eau
donc en fait quand il y a pas beaucoup
d'eau c'est un peu compliqué de produire
de l'énergie quand il y a pas beaucoup
de soleil aussi ce qu'ils ont du
photovoltaïque qui est plutôt pas mal et
donc en fait la Suisse n'est pas loin de
du risque de blackout si un hiver très
très froid donc en fait les solidarités
avec les pays voisins c'est quelque
chose qui doit aller naturellement et
par ailleurs la Suisse s'investit
beaucoup dans les domaines de
l'hydrogène d'autres énergies des
carbonées et donc il y a vraiment un
intérêt commun
à poursuivre les relations à aller de
l'avant dans l'innovation pour justement
avoir un fonctionnement énergétique le
plus efficace possible Emmanuel Macron a
lancé à Prague la communauté politique
européenne réunissant 44 chefs d'État
européens donc la Suisse qui était
représenté cette nouvelle instance
peut-être aussi permettre de d'aider aux
relations entre l'UE et la Suisse et les
dynamiser selon vous alors évidemment
j'étais très heureux de l'initiative
d'Emmanuel Macron et moi je suis
intervenu tout de suite pour dire
invitons la Suisse il se trouve que
c'était ce qui était prévu donc ça ça
tombait très très bien et la Suisse est
venue ce qui est aussi un bon signal
parce que je pense que aujourd'hui dans
cette phase où on n'a pas d'accord avec
la Suisse plus on donnera des deux côtés
des signaux positifs plus on sera en
capacité d'arriver à la table de
négociation pour pour un nouvel accord
donc c'était important que Ignacio
cassis soit présent à cette réunion de
la communauté politique européenne à
Prague
d'ailleurs il s'est engagé d'ailleurs
dans un groupe de travail autour de
l'énergie à ce qui prouve que c'est un
sujet qui est important pour la Suisse
et donc c'est quelque chose de
effectivement très très positif
à poursuivre évidemment parce qu'il n'y
a pas que ce geste là il peut y avoir
d'autres sur le fond de cohésion comme
les Suisses s'ils sont des gens engagés
l'Union européenne peut sans doute aussi
faire des gestes sur un certain nombre
de politiques sur les alliances
européennes on peut avoir des consortium
Suisse Union européenne donc il faut
aller de l'avant il faut surtout pas
rester immobile sur sa chaise pour finir
Christophe grudeler passons maintenant
un autre petit sujet l'espace vous êtes
un député très investi sur la la
question on parle régulièrement de
lutter contre la pollution de notre
planète mais vous vous souhaitez aussi
lutter contre la pollution dans l'espace
actuellement la NASA surveille plus de
27000 débris spatiaux à ce jour alors
déjà Christophe Grudler comment se
fait-il que l'espace compte autant de
débris alors déjà il y a il y a la
mauvaise idée des Russes des Chinois
notamment qui ont eu
l'idée très original de d'envoyer un
missile pour détruire un satellite et
voir ce que ça donnera évidemment un de
leurs satellite et en fait quand vous
pulvérisez un satellite c'est des
dizaines de milliers de débris que vous
propulsez dans l'espace et un simple
boulon dans l'espace avec la vitesse de
propulsion peut complètement endommager
des satellites de de géolocalisation
d'observation c'était militaire civil
etc donc en fait chaque débris est
dangereux même s'il fait quelques
quelques centimètres alors la NASA
surveille mais la France aussi surveille
parce qu'il y a aussi des moyens de
surveillance en France
pour justement qu'on arrête la loi de la
jungle dans l'espace parce que
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
réglementation
si vous voulez on est un petit peu comme
au début de la voiture quand on avait
mis les premières automobiles sur les
routes il y a pas de code de la route
puisqu'il y avait que quelques voitures
puis quand il a commencé par beaucoup de
monde et ben on s'est dit ouh là on va
faire la côte de la route on va mettre
des feux tricolores des stops etc et
bien c'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui
dans l'espace parce que justement vous
avez demandé à la Commission européenne
de légiférer sur le sujet en proposant
une loi sur le trafic spatial vous
voulez que cette loi soit donc voter
avant 2024 l'année prochaine donc
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce texte
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il porte
il faut bien voir qu'il y a des milliers
de satellites qui vont être lancés d'ici
2024 dans l'espace donc
mon souhait c'est que la Commission sans
poignent prennent rapidement le sujet
pour qu'on ait une loi européenne sur la
gestion du trafic dans l'espace et que
cette loi européenne nous permette après
d'aller devant l'ONU dans d'autres
instances mondiales pour
global il nous faut les Russes
si on sort de l'impasse les Chinois il
nous faut les Américains parce qu'il
faut que tous ceux qui ont des
satellites en fait soit d'accord pour
une régulation du trafic alors ça veut
dire aussi peut-être des transpondeurs
sur les sur les satellites comme il y en
a sur les bateaux ce qui permet de toute
façon les satellites militaires on sait
tous que c'est les 7000 militaires ils
sont absorbés par les autres donc il y a
pas de secret donc ça permet
effectivement d'avoir des alertes
anti-collision assez en amont sans être
obligé de surveiller mais la pollution
c'est pas que les débris la pollution
c'est aussi le le bilan CO2 des
lancements qui qu'il faut aujourd'hui
afficher pour pouvoir montrer que
l'espace c'est bon pour la planète avec
notamment des satellites qu'on va lancer
qui vont surveiller le dégagement de CO2
d'origine humaine les nouveaux
Copernicus et puis la pollution c'est
également la pollution lumineuse et
quand on voit monsieur musk qui avec
Starlink envoie des chariots de
satellites qu'on peut voir depuis la
Terre tout le monde est content c'est
beau ces petites lumières etc mais ça va
nous empêcher d'observer l'espace pour
nos pour nos pour nos astronautes qui
plus aucune possibilité d'observation et
la lumière c'est vraiment aussi une
forme de pollution merci beaucoup
Christophe merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous dans une robe je rappelle que vous
êtes député européen membre du groupe
prinus Europe au Parlement européen
Europe
c'est terminé vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur notre site
Internet ou sur notre application radio
sensation et aussi sur tv78 à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]